traum vom mount everest zu erfüllen im
mittelpunkt stehen die sherpas die ihren
kunden diesen traum ermöglichen die
rasten tragen und dem weg zum gipfel
vorbereitung dieser film zeigt das leben
der sherpas und ihre arbeit am everest
wie sie ihre bergsteiger sichern wenn
die kraft auf 8600 meter schwindet
es ist die geschichte über ihren
verdienten gipfelerfolg es ist aber auch
ein film der zeigt wie sich die sherpas
wird das leben ihrer kunden einsetzen
und sich dadurch selber in todesgefahr
bringen
[Applaus]
in der wohnung des großereignisses
konntest du bist uns nicht haben wie ihn
seine fans
[Musik]
unsere helden sind norbu sherpa
29-jährige ein junger sherpa aus
kathmandu
es ist mental und physisch sehr
anstrengend man braucht viel kraft und
jung ist hat man diese kraft aber diesen
job kann man nicht ewig und london
42 eine legende er stammt 13 mal auf dem
gipfel des everest mit dem einkommen
einer expedition muss ich meine familie
ein ganzes jahr lang nähern
deshalb bin ich gezwungen als sherpa zu
arbeiten
es ist ende märz im kleinen dörfchen
tammo auf 3.490 m
sie sind ein volksstamm der vor 500
jahren von tibet nach nepal gezogen ist
sie leben von der landwirtschaft haben
aber schnell begriffen dass mit
westlichen expeditionen mehr geld zu
verdienen ist
so auch languedoc der sala frau auf dem
feld hilft
sein vater starb bereits früh ich weiß
wen ich von meinem vater er war auch im
business meine mutter blieb daheim und
erledigte die hausarbeit
wir hatten auch jaxx die wir im sommer
auf die hoch beiden brachten und im
winter beiden ziel meine mutter
verkaufte butter und joghurt longuet hat
es dank seiner stärke und seiner
körpergröße weit gebracht
[Applaus]
seine 13 everest erfolge beeindrucken
sowohl die einfachen bauern wie auch dem
buddhistischen lama die buddhistische
religion spielt im leben der sherpas
eine große rolle
so bekommt der lama eine kleine gabe und
einen glücksfall
dort lebt mit seiner frau pasang kiki in
seinem elternhaus mit dem geld aus den
expeditionen schicken sie ihre beiden
töchter nach kathmandu in die schule
sie hoffen dass ihre kinder dadurch ein
besseres leben führen
ja vielleicht sogar ins ausland ziehen
können london sie leidet darunter dass
er nie eine ausbildung bekam er musste
früher verantwortung für die familie
übernehmen
es gab viele gründe warum ich nicht
studieren konnte meine brüder gingen in
die schule mich nicht
ich musste das vieh hüten dann nahm der
älteste bruder meine zwei jüngeren
brüder nach kathmandu mit und ich blieb
allein zu hause
ich wuchs mit den yaks auf den alpweiden
aus dann wurde ich träger für
verschiedene tracking gruppen und lernt
leute kennen
so gewann ich erfahrungen in diesem
beruf und da ich starke schlau war habe
ich auch meine arbeit gut verrichtet die
meisten leute haben mich gerne
angestellt seine beiden brüder leben
heute in amerika blieb das einfache
leben von tammo hier feiert die
hochzeitsgesellschaft seiner nichte in
seinem haus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dank des bergsteigens erreichte dort die
berühmtheit und wohlstand kathmandu
die hektische hauptstadt nepals mit über
1,2 millionen einwohnern ist sie das
zentrum des landes
es ist ein schmelztiegel vieler kulturen
und religionen und auch sitz der größten
buddhistischen stupa des landes jene von
bodner
hier lebt norbert scherpe als kind wurde
er von seiner familie zu einer tante
nach darjeeling geschickt wo er eine
gute ausbildung bekam er versuchte im
ausland einen job zu ergattern
doch er wurde opfer einer schlepperbande
verlor sein vermögen und landete wieder
in kathmandu hier fand er schließlich
einen job im büro der tracking agentur
von sherpa dotschy dem partner des
schweizer bergführers kari kobler
man lernt viel mehr wenn man von
kathmandu aus zum bergsteigen geht als
wenn man im dorf geblieben ist hat man
zugang zum computer und so viele
kontakte zu ausländern die arbeit vor
dem computer würde ihm aber bald zu
langweilig auf sein drängen hin bekam er
die chance auf expeditionen mitzugehen
zuerst als küchenjunge darauf als hoch
träger als sogenannter climbing sherpa
climbing sherpas die in kathmandu leben
haben gute möglichkeiten geld zu
würdigen und sich eine bessere zukunft
aufzubauen
nabu möchte nicht dein leben lang diesen
gefährlichen und anstrengenden job als
climbing sherpa ausüben sondern später
den ruhm das geld und seine kontakte
nutzen um sich weiter zu entwickeln
im jazzhaus findet wie vor jeder
expedition eine feierliche zeremonie
eine sogenannte pusher statt
die mönche sind aus dem benachbarten
buddhistischen kloster in seiner
ausgekommen
[Musik]
ohne eine solche butscher würde
longboard sie nie zum everest gehen denn
die sherpas schulung mal nennen
jamuna ist ein eckert in für uns wir
beten zu er bevor wir aufsteigen
wir bitten sie um erlaubnis und beten
dass niemandem etwas passiert
und wieder einmal packt london seinen
rucksack für die nächsten zwei monate
es ist das erste mal dass ich für eine
schweizer expedition und kari kobler
unterwegs bin ich freue mich als gute
und kehrt zurück das wünsche ich dir
auch über arbeite dich nicht jetzt gehe
ich pass auf dich auf tottis frau ist
von heute an zwei monate allein
ich bin besorgt wenn das wetter schlecht
ist wenn leute vorbeikommen will ich
immer wissen ob sie neuigkeiten von
deutsche haben in mir jemand nicht
antwortet befürchte ich stets dass sie
mir irgendwelche schlechte nachrichten
vorenthalten will
[Musik]
mir geht es erst wieder gut wenn er
zurückgekehrt ist
es ist ende märz 2008 in flughafen von
kathmandu ist der schweizer bergführer
kari kobler mit seinen
expeditionsteilnehmern gelandet
london und andere sherpas erwarten kari
kobler führt seit acht jahren
expeditionen zum es durch er selber
stand bereits dreimal auf dem gipfel
er wird vom neuen expedition mitgliedern
und begleitet
jeder hat 40.000 franken bezahlt um sich
seinen traum vom everest durch kari und
seine organisation erfüllen zu lassen
london sie nutzt die zeit um sich auch
in kathmandu von seiner familie zu
verabschieden
er trifft sie im haus seiner schwester
seine töchter gegen hier zur schule
die jüngere ist nur die zähne in einem
kloster und die ältere besucht eine
privatschule
ich bin studentin wenn ich den lehrern
der schule fragt was mein vater mache
dann sage ich das eher bergsteigen sei
wenn mein vater den gipfel bezwingt bin
ich glücklich wenn ich den beruf meines
vaters beschreibe fühle ich mich stolz
jeden morgen bete ich zu gott dass mein
vater erfolg hat und heil nach hause
kommt an den abschied können sie sich
nie gewöhnen
zu groß ist die angst dass der vater
einmal nicht mehr zurückkommen könnte
[Musik]
inzwischen befindet sich die expedition
von kari kobler im anflug auf lukla
[Musik]
das dorf auf 2.860 metern ist
ausgangspunkt jeder everest expedition
auch für die beiden walliser teilnehmer
und bergführer meinrad kittel und
patrick brune der meisten unter der
haube everest ohne sauerstoff bestiegen
hängt und ich habe die damalige
expeditionsleiter vorwärts und rückwärts
klasse und hatte hier täglich in bester
erinnerung
und das ist bis heute so geblieben und
mina ist gedanklich sie vor 25 jahren
meine der marktmacht einmal im mini abo
auf auch die signet das ist eigentlich
gedanken kukksi und jetzt in den letzten
zwei jahre sich plötzlich dazu
kristallisiert wie solid trakt an
harmonie war es kommen wenn im briefkopf
übernehmen süd kohlberger der küntroper
im ruf die bin ich auf 8000 und wenn ihr
nur mag noch wichtiger als klick hat als
sie plötzlich auf dem top-star der hexe
das ein absoluter knaller für mich
von lukla aus geht es für alle zu fuß
weiter
sieben tage trekking durch sherpa land
das sogenannte sole co
[Musik]
autos und straßen gibt es ja keine hacks
oder träger schleppen die lasten auch
das gepäck der expedition
am nächsten tag betreten sie durch
dieses tor den st agatha national park
sagarmatha heißt der mount everest in
nepal
[Musik]
auf rund 3000 meter erblicken sie in
weiter ferne zum ersten mal ihr ziel die
spitze des mount everest
[Applaus]
dort am fuße des everest auf 5300 meter
treffen unterdessen die ersten sherpas
nein es ist eine besondere gruppe die
jede im gletscher betritt
es sind am nima sherpa und seine eisfall
doktoren
ihr arbeitsplatz ist der gewaltige
scheinbar unüberwindbare kuh eisfall das
tor zum moor ist diese sherpas werden
hier einen weg für die expedition
vorbereiten um sich vor den gefahren zu
schützen
zelebrieren sie im basislager eine
botschaft
ausgerüstet mit leitern und seilen
wachen sie sich auf in das eislabyrinth
der namen eisfall doktoren bekamen sie
von zwei everest veteranen die sie einst
bei ihrer arbeit beobachtet hatten
sie sahen zu wie er arbeitet wir legen
die leitern r drehen an den schrauben
schlagen mit dem eis hammer zu und
fixieren die seile
vielleicht hätten sie das für arbeit von
doktoren zuerst nannte man uns
jedenfalls eisfall arbeiter aber dann
sagten alle das sind eisfall doktoren
bevor ein westlicher werkstatt über je
einen fuß in den ice fall setzt beginnen
die sherpas rundum anima ihre
gefährliche arbeit
der ice fall bewegt sich je nach
schätzungen zwischen 30 zentimetern und
einem meter pro tag
und der ice war ist wie popcorn oben
bedeckt von schnee und unten offen
an verschiedenen stellen kann man dabei
echo ähnliche geräusche dann weiß man
dass hier in der nächsten tagen das eis
brechen wird
anima kennt den ice war wie kein zweiter
seit 1975 muss er mit seinem team jedes
jahr einen neuen weg zwischen den
haushohen gletscher abbrechen suchen
dieser platz ist sicher platziert sie
dort dann schon
ja
[Musik]
inzwischen in lhasa auf 3400 meter
es ist der hauptort des solo combo
gebietes ein geschäftiges bergdorf mit
internet deutsche bäckerei und vielen
touristen jobs man nennt es auch
kleinster
[Musik]
die expeditionsteilnehmer machen hier
einen tag pause um sich an die höhe zu
gewöhnen
gemeinsam steigen sie zu einem
aussichtspunkt hoch es präsentiert sich
ihnen ein fantastisches bergpanorama
mit dem spitzen amada plan bei den
wallisern kommen heimatgefühl hoch und
über allem thront der mount everest der
bergführer richard bolt erklärt die
eigenheiten des everest 92 15
und jetzt willst du zum vierzehnten mal
auf den berg mehr
erstaunlich
am fuße des everest im eis wahl geht die
arbeit der ausfall doktoren derweil
weiter an ihrer sucht eine sichere route
vorsichtig tastet er sich voran
denn es besteht die gefahr in eine
verdeckte gletscherspalte zu stürzen
hast du keinen weg gefunden nein nicht
auf dieser seite
es ist gefährlich die andere seite ist
besser auch wenn sie länger ist eine
leiter genügt dort
hier müssen wir fünf zusammenbinden rund
55 bis 60 leiter und 3500 meter seil
werden sie in den nächsten tagen verlegt
die gefährliche arbeit hinterlässt
allerdings spuren
selbst in der nacht schreckt am lima
immer wieder auf und träumt vom weiß war
im basislager auf 5340 metern treffen
derweil yaks und die träger mit dem
material für die verschiedenen
expeditionen nicht weniger als 41 werden
erwartet die sherpas von kari kobler
expedition sind damit beschäftigt einen
guten lagerplatz im eis herauszuhalten
[Applaus]
dann können sie die vielen zelte der
expedition aufstellen
so entsteht das neue zuhause für ihre
westlichen bergsteiger diese nähren sich
der wahl schritt für schritt dem base
camp geschäftstüchtige sherpas haben am
weg über als souvenir stände aufgebaut
[Musik]
die walliser sind beeindruckt vom
einfachen leben der sherpas und ihrem
tief verwurzelten glauben der überall
präsent ist
[Musik]
in kambodscha auf 3.860 metern liegt das
wichtigste buddhistische kloster des
thales zeit für jeden bergsteiger einen
moment innezuhalten
zweimal wurde das kloster durch
katastrophen zerstört und wieder
aufgebaut
das kloster ist aber total
niedergebrannt
es hatte winter nicht mehr aber dann ist
es sehr kalt im winter ja aber er lebt
tief unten und wir hoch oben
unser blut ist sehr stark ich bin ein
junger mann
ich muss jetzt rein danach können wir
weiter sprechen dass die kälte gar nicht
[Musik]
im basislager herrscht inzwischen
hochbetrieb
expeditionsleiter kari kobler ist
eingetroffen und kontrolliert die
aufbauarbeiten zwischen den eisbrocken
platzieren die sherpas mehrere große
zelte wie hier das material zählt und
auch die gefährliche arbeit im eis fall
geht voran mit mehr kraft ja komm mit
mehr kraft sie haben die gefährlichste
stelle im eis fall erreicht man nennt
sie den damm fünf leitern haben sie
zusammen gebunden um voranzukommen
ihr müsst sie dort hinauf ziehen wenn
ihr sie zusammen gefunden habt dahinter
hat sein großes loch die hoch und schaue
wie groß es ist die spalte sehr groß
das wissen wir wenn wir den rand
erreicht haben
wenn es dort nicht weitergeht müssen wir
alle sachen mitnehmen und woanders einen
weg suchen
bald schon werden hunderte von
bergsteigern über diese leitung steigen
die von am lima und seinem team verlegt
wurden und ohne die die meisten everest
aspiranten nie eine chance auf den
gipfel hätten
weiter unten im tal führen long deutsche
und norbu ihrer expeditionsteilnehmer
ins haus von lama gesche in kambodscha
alle bergsteiger sollen von ihm eine
segnung erhalten auch nabu der junge
moderne sherpa würde nie ohne segnungen
an den everest gehen
ich habe einen tiefen glauben ob schon
nicht gut ausgebildet bin und der
kantone und nicht in einem dorf
ich praktiziere man den glauben auch in
der stadt vor der zeremonie übergibt
lama gesche junge deutsche und norbu
karten welche der expedition glück
bringen sollen
jeder bekommt eine solche karte viele
leute haben eine solche karte bis auf
den gipfel des everest mitgenommen und
sie dort mit ihr fotografieren lassen
jeder von euch bekommt bitte hebt sie
auf und tragen sie auf euch war immer
ihr aufsteigt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leben und tod liegen am everest nahe
beieinander
davon zeugen den dukla diese steinernen
gedenkstätten
sie erinnern an all die menschen die am
everest ihr leben gelassen haben
über 200 tote hat der everest bis jetzt
gefordert darunter viele westliche
bergsteiger aber auch sherpas
und auch von dieser expedition wird eine
nicht mehr zurückkehren
solche reliquienschreine erinnern uns an
die toten
nach der kremation bringen die trauer
familien ein stück knochen vom toten und
vermischen es mit leben
dann gehen sie zum lama formen an die
statue daraus und opfern geld danach
bauen sie ein solches stein monument und
bewahren die stadt will und asche des
toten darin auf
eigentlich ein gleiches schicksal
erleben kann und eben nicht mehr erleben
könnte gianni goltz der tessiner stand
bereits auf sechs 8000 an
nach sieben tagen kommen die bergsteiger
im basecamp an
dieses ist mittlerweile zu einer
riesigen zeltstadt angewachsen
41 expeditionen sind 2008 hier
versammelt das sind rund 1000 personen
bergsteiger sherpas und andere helfer
kari kobler allein beschäftigt 15
sherpas eine meiner ältesten sherpas mit
ihm habe ich schon everest bestiegen
schon eben gerade letztes jahr ständig
wenn die branche hat schon viele sachen
für uns gemacht hätte sagt war mit uns
in pakistan
er war letztes jahr als autobahn als
eine unserer bekanntesten zusammen mit
norbert euro gehört auch zu unseren top
cracks und ich hoffe sie helfen uns
david wir uns nachher beglückwünschen
können den everest bestiegen zu haben
danke für immer wie hat car ist ein team
zusammengestellt
es geht ein paar wichtige faktoren das
zum beispiel es zwei mögliche regionen
sind zeigt jetzt mal mit 120 region
das ist so zur aus
das stein ist wo sie einfach rein dafür
sie werden jetzt zweiter sich das war
eine prima ist passiert dass der anderen
hälfte und demenz aus der region sie
noch eine starke haarweg konditionell
stark nicht gut englisch präsentiert
trägt einfach das sind suchmaschinen der
motor vor dem sherpa thema noch eine
kids die antwort ich denke wo einfach
das ganze koordiniert und dann geht es
die andere wo der anbieter so lustig
sind welche witze erzählt war einfach
druckbaren versagt sache offenen
hoffnung in den guten ruf bringen
in den nächsten wochen werden die
sherpas vom basislager aus weitere lager
einrichten lager 1 auf 5900 meter lager
2 auf 6400 meter lager 3 auf 7300 meter
und lager 4 auf 7900 sie werden diese
wege rauf und runter gehen und dabei
geld verdienen
der lohn wird vorher im basislager
ausgehandelt kari kobler bezahlt ein
grundsalär von 2000 dollar
dazu kommt der leistungslohn je nachdem
wie oft ein sherpa innen hochlager
aufsteigt und wie viel er trägt umso
mehr geld kann er verdienen na gut der
junge soldat oder chef der sherpas
übersetzt die vorschläge von kari die
sherpas haben ihre eigenen vorstellungen
es folgen lohnverhandlungen wie auf dem
basar
lasst uns mehr grundlohn verlangen statt
mehr bonus andere gruppen zahlen 2200
dollar
lasst uns verhandeln ja wir sollten
jetzt waren
wie steht es mit den zahlungen oben wir
sollten etwas mehr verlangen für lager
31 kennt drei gehen wir ja nur einmal
oder und so wird um den lohn für jedes
hochlager gefälscht
ihr wollt 50 ich will 40 zahlen also
sagen wir 45
alle sollen zufrieden sein und ist ich
mag es nicht wenn ihr nicht zufrieden
sein
45 ist okay dann camp 3 wie viel für
camp 4
mein letzter preis für camp 4 120
das ist harte arbeit das weiß jeder
seid ihr einverstanden ja er ist der
härteste mann
ein sherpa verdient für diese expedition
zwischen 4500 und 5500 dollar je nach
leistung mit 1 anschaffen das ist so
eines autonomes gebildet wo es über
jahre lang und die strukturen in der ghv
niveau niveau sie wüssten deshalb muss
es funktioniert und das funktioniert
sherpas wie london verdienen in den
folgenden zwei monaten rund das doppelte
jahressalär eines lehrer sind gradmann
du dafür leisten sie aber fast
übermenschliches und riskieren ihr leben
wie ist dort sie mit den verhandlungen
zufrieden es war gut die diskussionen um
den bonus waren auch gut
alle kollegen sind zufrieden in den
nächsten zwei monaten entsteht eine
schicksalsgemeinschaft zwischen sherpas
und expeditionsteilnehmer ihren freiraum
haben die sherpas in ihren kirchen zelt
mit eigenem koch der nepalesische
gerichte kocht wie hier die du ein
gersten gericht
[Musik]
das zelt ist aufenthalts herum
hier wird gegessen diskutiert und
gelacht ohne westliche bergsteiger die
expeditionsteilnehmer haben ihr eigenes
zelt ihre eigene küche und angenehmen
luxus auf 5340 metern
das zelt ist geheizt jeden abend werden
sie mit einem 3 gang menü überrascht
gekocht und serviert von der schärfe
küchenmannschaft gekocht wird nach dem
geschmack der gäste
heute zum beispiel pommes frites und
muss
[Musik]
gemeinsam ist allen das ziel der mount
everest
wir respektieren den everest als unsere
mutter gebe es keinen everest können sie
sich vorstellen wie dann unser leben
während wir sehen den berger sein
göttliches symbol
wir singen ein lied ich kam zu dir bitte
liebe mich wieso man stets das mantra om
mani padme am 17 april 2008 findet im
basislager die buddhistische kuchar
statt
dieser tag verheißt im kalender der
sherpas viel glück steigeisen und pickel
werden gesegnet
ein berg steigender lama führt durch die
zeremonie und murmelt mantras vorsicht
opfer gaben sollen die götter milde
stimmen
[Musik]
während der rund zweistündigen zeremonie
ziehen die sherpas bunte gebetsfahnen
über das ganze lager
der wind sollte gebete in alle
himmelsrichtungen tragen und glück
bringen
[Musik]
dazu kommen irdische finanzielle opfer
gaben die der lama bekommt ganz gratis
ist auch diese zeremonie nicht
[Musik]
zum abschluss der putter werfen alle
mail in die luft ich fühlte mich in den
letzten tagen nicht sehr gut
nun ist die zeremonie endlich vorbei
jetzt ist alles in ordnung
ich bin glücklich doch in diesem jahr
ist vieles anders
wir schreiben das jahr 2008 und die
chinesen wollen die olympische fackel
auf den everest bringen die palette
militär helikopter landen im basecamp
soldaten soll dafür sorgen dass keine
anti chinesischen aktionen am everest
stattfinden nepal beugt sich dem
politischen druck vom großen nachbarn
china an einer versammlung mit den rund
500 bergsteigern mitgeteilt dass der
berg von nun an gesperrt ist
niemand darf weiter aufsteigen als lager
2 bevor die chinesen nicht auf dem
gipfel waren diese soldaten werden alles
überwachen die expeditionen ist zur
kenntnis und beginnen mit den
vorbereitungen zum aufstieg in die 2
freigegebenen hochlager zuerst wird die
riesige menge von nahrung aufgeteilt
jeder von euch bekommt einen sack und
später nehmen wir noch an den zweiten
die expeditionsteilnehmer wie patrick
gruhn bekommen solche säcke in die sie
ihr persönliches material packen und den
sherpas mitgeben
das ist nicht genug
es sollten zwölf kilo seien für jeden
wir geben hier einen zweiten sagt dazu
ich wieder alles um das genaue gewicht
zu kennen
a
erstes ziel ist das lager 1 auf 5900
meter
der weg führt vom basislager durch den
ausfall bereits um 3 uhr morgens machen
sich die sherpas auf den weg
[Musik]
das ist das leben der sherpas
was kann man da machen
sherpas aller expeditionen wollen heute
für ihre teilnehmer das material ins
lager 1 hinauf bringen alle folgende
route welche die eisfall doktoren gelegt
haben
bereits morgens um 5 uhr kommt es zu
ersten staus im eis fall
der aufstieg ist schwierig auch für
erfahrene sherpas win or go ist es nicht
leicht auf über 5500 metern lasten von
20 kilo oder mehr zu transportieren
[Musik]
etwas später starten die
expeditionsteilnehmer am einstieg zum
ausfall werden sie wie angekündigt vom
nepalesischen militär kontrolliert ein
soldat notiert fein säuberlich jeden
bergsteiger um festzuhalten wanner
hinauf und wieder hinunter geht
das darf die beiden walliser bergführer
aber nicht stört
zum ersten mal wagen sie sich über die
von den ausfall doktoren gelegten leiter
auch für die bergführer ist es eine
mutprobe ein fehltritt könnte fatale
folgen haben
doch langsam und konzentriert
bewegen sie sich auf der ungewohnten
will
nach drei stunden erreichen die sherpas
lager 1 auf 5900 meter
sie stellen die zelte für ihre kunden
auf denen dieses hochlager zur
akklimatisation dient fixiert jährige
auf allen vier seiten
die sherpas verankern die zelte
deponieren das material und steigen
wieder ab ins basislager um weiteres
gepäck hoch zu schleppen
so auch lang deutsche auswahl spitzt
sich die situation auf 5800 meter für
die aufsteigenden mitglieder der kobler
expedition zu unerfahrene everest
aspiranten versperren den weg und
blockieren die leiter vorsichtig rücken
unsere bergführer nach
inzwischen kommen ihnen die ersten job
als bereits wieder entgegen
was alle befürchten passiert durch die
masse der bergsteiger entsteht ein stau
auf über 5800 meter
mai
dafür sind bei ihrer ankunft im lager 1
alle zelte aufgestellt und das
persönliche material deponiert
patrick und meinrad werfen einen blick
zur lotse flanke sie steigen wieder ab
ins basislager
im gegensatz zu den anderen übernachten
sie erst später im lager 1
im eisfach müssen anima und seine
eisfall doktoren neue leitern und seilen
legen dass sich die eismassen ständig
bewegen und hunderte von leuten zur
gleichen zeit auf und absteigen diese
verrückten gletscherspalte
heute haben wir einen neuen weg
ausprobiert
durch die wärme löst sich lawinen die
den eisfall donnern patrick und wein rat
kommen wohlbehalten im basecamp an
für jemanden als apple scheint es
logisch also zeigt euch natürlich der
brief gang zum teil vierten stunde
er lacht das erinnert
die sherpas arbeiten die nächsten sechs
wochen praktisch ohne unterbruch kam
zurück im basislager packen sie neues
material das sie in den nächsten tagen
ins lager zwei hinauftragen werden auch
norden ist zurück lasst uns die sachen
aufteilen schauen wir zuerst mal das
material der members an dann die ice
schrauben die seile die fans hat ich
liebe es zwar in den bergen oder auf dem
gipfel zu sein
aber der anfang einer expedition
dann ist der job sehr hart entlasten
zelte ausstellt das alles ist sehr sehr
hart
und das sehen sie in der nächsten folge
die sherpas bauernhof 6400 meter lager 2
auf bahn.de leidet ich habe
fürchterliche kopfschmerzen wenn ich
mich vorbeuge habe ich das gefühl zu
fall
norbu ist gefordert und organisiert
alles material für weitere hochlager
grausiger fund im lager 2 der gletscher
hat teile einer bergsteiger leiche
freigegeben
[Musik]
über 40 expeditionen wollen zur gleichen
zeit aufbrechen und wieder stau am
everest
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
sherpas die wahren helden am everest